طبعا مشاهدينا الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
للجديده ستعمل على الحد من التطور
التكنولوجي للصين الذي يخالف عقودا من
السياسه الفيدراليه و يمثل اجراء اداره
بيض حاليا الاكثر عدوانيه حتى الان لتقليس
تكنولوجيا الاقتصاد والعسكر البيكيني وذلك
وفقا لمسؤولينا امريكيين القواعد
الفيدراليه الجديده والاوامر التنفيذيه
والتشريعات المتعلقه التي تستهدف قطاعات
التكنولوجيا الفائقه في الصين والتي بدات
هذا العام وستمر في 20 23 هي تتويج
للسنوات من النقاش امتدا لثلاث ادارات
امريكيه
وليامز التي ساعدت في تصميم السياسه
الاقتصاديه لاداره ترامب قالت لبوليتكو ان
يعتبر الابتكار المحلي الصيني تهديد للامن
القومي في حد ذاته طبعا هذه هي قفزه كبيره
من ما كانت عليها امريكا من قبل كما ان
الاستراتيجيه الجديده التي تسميها اداره
دا يعني بجانده الحمايه ستكون قادره على
وقف قدره الشركات الصينيه على تصنيع
الرقائق الالكترونيه المتقدمه سيد بعد ذلك
قريبا امر تنفيذي بانشاء سلطه فدراليه
جديده لتنظيم الاستثمارات الامريكيه في
الصين سيما القطاع الالكتروني اضافه طبعا
الى عدم تخفيف القيود الجمركيه الامريكيه
المفروضه اصلا على التجاره الصينيه وذلك
منذ عهد دونالد ترامب
[موسيقى]